We can find the y-intercept of this curve by plugging in x equals 0. That gives
us a y-coordinate of 4, and we already know the x-coordinate is 0, so the
y-intercept is 0,4. X-intercepts are where y equals 0. Now, we need to factor to
figure out what x values makes this equation true. The two equations that yield
solutions that could each make this equation true are x plus 4 equals 0 and x
plus 1 equals 0. So now, I just have to solve each of these. Our x-intercepts
are then at negative 4,0 and negative 1,0. Lastly, let's find the vertex by
putting this in vertex form. Our final equation in vertex form is y plus 9 4th
equals x plus 5 halves squared. That means, that our vertex is at negative 5
halves, negative 9 4th. If you think about the fact that we talked about what
parabolas are for the first time just a couple of lessons ago, it's pretty
impressive how much you can do to manipulate them and find out about their
graphs already. This is really awesome. Good job.